yo what up it's grip y'all make sure
y'all check me out on the bootleg calf
podcast
yes ersky
boulay care podcast special guest my guy
good to see you man good to see you man
i'm also no c shady records newest
grip
what's happening everybody atlanta's
finest is in the building man welcome
man welcome hey first of all i just want
to say congratulations thank you thank
you yeah because i i remember uh when my
boy erica rock put me onto your [ __ ] uh
he put me on his thumbnails project
i was like oh i gotta fight i gotta find
this guy we gotta get him on the show
you wanna fight people that reached out
yeah man like it was so it's so dope and
then just to see you kind of like
just drop consistently throughout the
pandemic just dropping records and just
staying like staying on your [ __ ] man
and like obviously it paid off like kind
of take me to what led to em
coming to the table like what what what
caught his attention yeah i'll give you
the the months like the months leading
up to this [ __ ] so like we draw snug
nose in like october 2019 right right
shit's got them you know i was getting
critical acclaim and you know went on
tour with jay uh europe
uh came back like december like
christmas right
january we setting up for this brand
tour we found a tour de states with
brent right
then covey
and then everything shuts down and we're
kind of just like that have been a big
tour too my big tour yeah and we're
supposed to make some good money right
so like
it's like damn all right well what are
we going to do
so
automatically just start i just lock in
and i make halo mm-hmm you know i'm
saying i'm like hello and then i think
like a week and i'm like actually we're
releasing on band camp but he's that way
you know people can't get them just
tune in and throw some money out of that
right you made some money off of it yeah
so
like halo
you know did that [ __ ]
turn around mate probably yeah we kind
of just wait nobody know at this point
nobody knows like what's going on and
where's the world going back up right
everything's shut down everything's
getting canceled
i made that one
um i think shortly after i made that one
uh
i think paul
might have reached out you know yeah um
you know just show interest you know i'm
saying so at first it was just talks
with paul
and then it turned into well
emperor heard it and he you know i'm
saying he's interested so from there you
know we kind of just like
all right well let's figure something
out you know what i'm saying so this is
in the pandemic this is like this is
2019. right you know what i'm saying
2020. 2020. yeah 2020. yeah well she's
all [ __ ] up so this is all blur buddy
it's all [ __ ] blur man i'm a blur
right so i like it's 20 20 i just go
back to and at the start january i
started crew i started uh recording i
died for this okay january 20th so you
already started working on the album so
then after but then i took a pause i
recorded those other projects and and
put them out
um just to have some [ __ ] out yeah and
then once we talked to you know yeah i
mean paul it was kind of like all right
but like so now
i gotta i'm inspired again so like let
me finish this [ __ ] so that way if i fly
out there and [ __ ] and play some [ __ ]
for him i gotta you know you got a body
of work ready to go yeah yeah
so started working on continue working
on our die for this
um by the time we got up there uh
it was just like all i had to do was ask
him like yo this is the song i want you
on and you know i'm thinking about royce
on this [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
but i think that uh m said he here here
at snub nose and uh 226 caught him right
so
i'm
kind of rapping fast and switching
cadences and [ __ ] and uh big rubies at
the beginning he was like yeah he's like
that [ __ ]
so it was snub knows it caught his
attention yes no no it's kind of cuz i
feel like snub nose was so like slept on
especially like on the dsps
like i feel like once you started
dropping music in the pandemic like i
was like oh [ __ ] i see i see grip making
these [ __ ] big playlists this is dope
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah and
then people was going back to snuff
you know i'm saying so it was cool i
think every
like every drop i've ever had like it
just kind of got bigger yeah
you know what i'm saying like naturally
just it's got to be dope though like to
have like a concept project like snub
knows be the thing that catches eminem's
attention hell yeah man i felt like
because for a long time man i was i was
kind of upset with it because like i
felt like it was it was a great body of
work that kind of just like fell under
the radar no it definitely did yeah so
man i was just like you know
for a long time i was kind of just like
i was frustrated for people who don't
understand like you had a project in
2019 you put out called snub knows this
is the project that kind of got me onto
you real tough but what like it was a
whole entire concept to the album break
down what that was so um snub nose of
course is a is a revolver revolver yeah
so so pretty much i just like compare
like the mechanism
like the circular mechanism to like the
hood like just like our environment
um so like and kind of like spoke from
the perspective of a gun spoke on
different cycles
uh
and brought it back full circle at the
end so pretty much you know in a
nutshell like that's what it was it was
like the the most creative
ill
way to do what like nas and tupac did
but like over an entire body of work the
entire body of work and i just remember
like as a kid like hearing like i gave
you power oh i gave you powers the best
damn i think this is one of those songs
i was like
[ __ ] yeah maybe powers like one of those
songs you're like nazis with goat man
what the [ __ ] are we doing here i
remember like i remember like so
uh i think that it was just dope that
that at least em caught that [ __ ] you
know i'm saying like these this
kind of catapulted me to this next level
you know what i'm saying i mean that
means that the project served this
purpose
and think about illmatic right yo matic
i mean was was it was a underground
favorite i mean obviously it came out on
columbia but like
really once knives really started a pot
but a lot of people had to go back to
that back to that [ __ ] barely just went
double platinum like six months ago you
know what i'm playing
we're thinking is this like the holy
grail the holy grail of hip-hop and it's
like bro it's barely double platinum
yeah you know what i'm saying like i
guess it'd be like reasonable doubt same
thing right without reasonable how many
people like
no [ __ ] idea about reasonable doubt
until jay started really really getting
these commercial records and yeah so i
think that's kind of like your moment so
the the album like obviously when you
have a bodywork that's done you present
it to shady records right
you pick the song you want eminem on or
does he pick it well i did that i did i
don't know how i go usually but like i
was like
because when i played it
well i played it before i told him so
then when i played it he was like damn i
just hooked this hook is dope as [ __ ]
i was like oh [ __ ] well great it's the
one that's the one i wanted you know
that's the one i wanted you on yeah man
so like nah i kind of we are we kind of
catered you know sound like we kind of
catered that [ __ ] like to like all right
man let's if we was going to get him on
the song what would you know i'm saying
what i wanted to be what do i want this
[ __ ] to sound like so like that's kind
of like
why i kind of feel like it was easy for
him to just like walk straight into it
and it's got to be hard too because like
especially you brought up royce m you
know i always say royce and i mean royce
is a [ __ ] jedi he's a maniac one of
the greatest of all time
but
you would think
you wouldn't like
you get your m verse back you get your
voice verse back you already got your
[ __ ] done
right yeah so you gotta like it's almost
like
you gotta had already had recorded that
hoping that they was gonna get on it you
went super stupid hard yeah or did you
like recut any of your [ __ ] i don't
recut man i don't recut man i i respect
the you know i i respect the [ __ ]
because you know sometimes it's called
you'll send the record out with the hook
and then the open verse
see what see what's okay all right this
good i know i don't know what i need to
do it's a code for me so like if i most
of the time i saw that saying if an
artist is bigger than you mm-hmm they're
gonna they're gonna want to hear your
[ __ ] on their face right because they
don't want to look crazy
cool j cannabis [ __ ] happening yeah so
so you know out of respect and just like
you know like i said it's a cold man
like all right cool i'm gonna send it
with my [ __ ] on there i'm gonna try to
go as hard as possible but some
[ __ ] gonna flip some [ __ ] to go
crazy you know what i'm saying like and
it's just like hey it is what it is so
like we're uh with with them like with
royce with royce i had already had the
song constructed like the first half in
the second half so he just took the
whole middle you know i'm saying the
whole middle portion um and killed the
[ __ ] like which is what i was expecting
him to do anyways but then when i m [ __ ]
i spit at 16.
i was just trying to write some the most
[ __ ] right internal just did
that did that
lyrical scar
like i was going in you know at the same
time trying to like do my own thing so
uh when i send it to him
you know
and he sent back and i was like i was
already knowing that he was coming with
at least 36 bars you know what i'm
saying like i already knew i was like i
bet like
and he went in he just went the [ __ ] off
and it's like you know
i don't change [ __ ] you know so i never
i don't change nothing like any time
it's crazy too because like i just feel
like
um
you know what what i appreciate about
what eminem does
on shady is
it's not about cloud politics it's like
who's dope
yeah like who like look at boogie is
dope right right griselda guys fi like
people forget when eminem
brought griselda to shady like griselda
was buzzing and like
like amongst the hip-hop heads like boom
bap kids but it was nothing like it is
now yeah like
he's super early on you yeah you know
what i'm saying
and i think it's dope because like
a lot of times we'll see a lot of these
executives or artist turns executives
and it's really about like
it's really not it's not as much about
the talent and the capabilities as a
rapper as it is about like
the dollar signs you know what i'm
saying yeah man i think that's one of
the things when talking to him
of course i know it's a business you
know of course like when i talk to him
and [ __ ] it's like
you still felt like he was he's an
artist and like he kind of just like you
know what i'm saying it's like it's like
it's like a coach who used to play
basketball yeah
y'all's ass i think it's a difference
it's a difference
a coach who played in the nba yeah they
got different different respect with the
players that's why you always hear like
yeah man this guy fail me ex-player
always gets the locker room easier you
feel me like so like i felt that
you know i mean i felt that like before
we even
any paperwork anything you know i mean
he was just like yo like i don't want to
change nothing like i
you know i mean like pretty much that's
just great you creative controls i was
just like cool so you have creative
control in your situation yeah oh that's
fire that's big that's huge that's very
also very uh un
uncommon
yeah for real so um
obviously eminem is one of the greatest
rappers of all time um
i'm i mean obviously respect amazon mc
as far as like coming up like were you
listening to a lot of like
you know i'm not saying you were
listening to revival by the way you know
whatever if you were
but were you like like were you like
tapped in as like a pretty big eminem
fan coming up yeah yeah uh i was
i could probably spit for verbatim slim
shady lp all the way to the eminem show
those are my three yeah yeah and the
eight-mile soundtrack yeah ain't my
soundtrack i wish you would have made a
whole album when you have it right
bro if eminem would have did a whole
album when he was in eight mile [ __ ]
mode
them three records on eight mile [ __ ]
crazy yeah bro go hard there's some [ __ ]
on encore too remember the uh the uh the
men's types and [ __ ] the dj
yo he had a verse there was a song
called we all died one day
on ob trice's album
it was obi
lloyd banks 50 and eminem it's my
favorite eminem verse ever i feel like
no one talks about that verse but that
era of like yeah early g unit uh yeah
man eight mile
and when m was jumping on all the who
kid tapes the green lantern [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about job rule talking i
mean it was just like you know [ __ ] yeah
it's one of the best eras ever man on
the end bro uh so yeah no i was i was
yeah i was big on him
like before what's your favorite album
from him
like favorite i'm not saying best um
because i think they're different [ __ ]
probably the maybe the ammo show that's
my favorite yeah maybe the m show i
think like probably the best you could
probably say is marshall matters over
but to me eminem shows the one yeah
because i think uh my like marginal math
is lp like i i went in and i remember
the first time i literally broke i
vividly remember
like my big sister had just maybe she
had just got our license and some [ __ ]
and and we just driving up the street to
i'm on can we go to the to the gas
station or whatever right right and fly
norfolk city and you know sound like
literally just when there's some wild
[ __ ] i'm gonna kill you yeah you don't
want to [ __ ] be seen
like so it was hard bro i'm like mom
turn that [ __ ] off you're gonna take my
cd and throw it out
and i could i could hear like how his
style had changed and [ __ ] yeah
him adjusting to you know to the
industry and [ __ ] so it was dope man but
i i'll probably say the eminent show
yeah yeah mm shows my [ __ ] so um
what's been dope about just watching
atlanta over the last like five or six
years it's just like
atlanta obviously well for the last 20
to 25 it's been 20 strong years where
atlantis ran rap music right yeah um
but like just in terms of like you know
obviously there's amigos 21 savage
chains like all these guys who've been
like superstars shaping the culture
but
to see guys like
jid
to see black to see yourself like
oh like i like atlanta always to me was
like
you know growing up outcast was my
favorite [ __ ] like equipment is my
second favorite album ever
and like it's just dope that like
there's still that like
like lineage of like you know
that's that energy still coming out of
the air
and what's dope about it too is now it's
like
you know i'm sure when you were growing
up and when i when we were probably
coming up around the same era
it felt like hip-hop was a lot more
segregated yeah it'd be like this is the
real rap [ __ ] just the commercial [ __ ]
yeah yeah this is the boombap [ __ ] but
now i feel like everyone just [ __ ] with
each other like it's like you know do
you remember how crazy it was
when talib quality did a song
uh with jay-z yeah
or it wasn't even that it was it was it
wasn't even that it was it wasn't even
that actually i take that back it was
just the fact that jay shouted out to
lip quality in a song didn't even do a
record together it was he when he said
lyrically i'd be telling quality
everybody's like oh my god he shouted
out tyler like common sense right
[Music]
common sense
but it's crazy to think like
we came from an era when like
the rocket [ __ ] the common [ __ ] the
black star [ __ ] was like another world
from nas and jay-z because they were
commercially successful artists but i
feel like nowadays like everything
blends in together yeah somewhat for the
most part yeah like you would see like
you know
griselda doing records with two chains
yeah you know what i'm saying and i
think that come out of like just like
that but see like for instance like
outcasts and and uh
and [ __ ] um
who who would jump on nation uh i am a
frequent a frequent collaborator too
like like they had my husband wu-tang
respect thing like like oh no i see
y'all doing our thing with it like and
if if time allows like [ __ ] let's that's
why we think about like even like big
boy right he's just he put out
he's i mean i just think like as a kid
like to to think that like a trapped out
rapper like jeezy would do a song with
outcast it just wouldn't make sense to
me as a fan yeah but it seems but now
yeah but it's like i'm just glad that
like
because i used to be one of them little
hip-hop sniper i mean that ain't real
rap [ __ ] man
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] man but it's
like all this [ __ ] is fun it's all it's
all yeah
it's uh how do you feel about like kind
of the current state of atlanta and just
like where it is as far as like artist
integrity like i feel like atlanta still
runs this whole [ __ ] bro like yeah
um i think that uh i think it's in a
good place man i think that uh has a
decent balance you know what i'm saying
i feel like uh
the trap the trout [ __ ] or at least the
trap sound right i'm saying because it
started off as trout because [ __ ]
talking about trap right [ __ ] now it's
just it's just the sound yeah right so
like
uh
i feel like um
[Music]
even if it's if it it may not have been
it's like as hard as it was like ten
years ago but it's still like the
hardest [ __ ] is
it dominates the airwaves you know i'm
saying like it's it's more uh friendly
on the ear now you know i'm saying like
kids can [ __ ] with it
and everybody right muff egg 21 savage
gonna wrap his ass off amigos
literally probably the most influential
rappers in the last like decade so i saw
i felt with it bro and then on the uh on
just like the the lyrical side of things
you know just like
i feel like we all gotta
like we kind of [ __ ] with these like for
the most part everybody [ __ ] with each
other right right you know what i'm
saying in atlanta you know i'm saying
some on the lyrical [ __ ] so like like i
said like j like j.i.d like that's the
homie and [ __ ] so like you know we
talked earth gangs out there you know
kenny mason kenny mason was just here he
free stuff he's a [ __ ] beast yeah
he's an alien you know me and [ __ ] man
so like
you know i think it's in a good spot bro
hey what up man we got to interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at odd socks now when i be
riding for odd socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview uh what's your in your opinion
uh what like if you if somebody was
coming to atlanta and they'd never been
to a strip club what would be the one
place you'd be like you got to go here
probably going to major city i went to
magic city i was disappointed did i eat
the wings they weren't good
they were all right
were you there cook
i was very disappointed they were tiny
ass wings bro you know that magic city
you want the jumbo wings bro you know
that magic city wings are small as hell
you want a jumbo wing are they not small
ass wings depends
on one night man you i wing this a
weenie inside bro i heard the blue flame
is is better food-wise maybe i don't
know guess what killer mike told me no
no i'm going i ain't going i ain't going
but
going to say yeah he's a head on the
flank
all right let's see if we talk about
food hey [ __ ] cheetah is a five-star
restaurant and that's like a they play
like nickelback in there right i don't
know what they play yeah they do yeah
yeah i mean
look at this
yo jaren benton tried to take me to the
claremont lounge oh yeah that's like a
real scum little freak show you said
there was midgets and elderly women
there bro one arm one one leg ladies and
[ __ ] that's nice you've been in there
yeah i mean they're not coming home yeah
he was like yo i'm gonna take you to
this place bro it's crazy
[ __ ] old women in one arm
yeah man midgets
all kinds of [ __ ] it's one of them
i could imagine like that [ __ ] being
there like tijuana or some [ __ ] you know
like just a just a random night just
drive down there and just like you ever
been to tj no man we plan on going soon
man i got a homie in san diego go to san
diego check out tj they got great
mexican food
great mexican food yeah man
yeah they got the tacos every corner the
bed the best tacos yeah he's probably
gonna hit that [ __ ] yeah 100 so the
album is out um
what is like because i think like you
know obviously with
i don't know how your deal is structured
but what was kind of cool about what
happened with griselda was like they
were signed to shady but they also were
just dropping independent [ __ ] yeah and
it was like yo what the [ __ ] is going on
right right is this on shady is this not
on shady like conway still hasn't
dropped his shady records album and i
heard it like a year ago like
yeah but like um
what's like your situation are you gonna
just flood the [ __ ] marketplace
so like that [ __ ] was released uh
it was distributed to shady um i died
for this uh
so that's straight society
through shady
distribution
um but yeah man so i mean technically we
haven't even
had a debut
so technically they just distributed the
project yeah technically yeah so they
haven't had a debut shady album yet but
we'll be one for sure
are you already working on it yeah
okay okay is that going to be something
where you like let him come in and maybe
do some executive producing or you kind
of got you got the creative control yeah
if the executive produces it you're
going to have skyler gray singing on
every [ __ ] hook i know
i'm gonna swap that out you can't
[ __ ] you're gonna have pink and
skylar grace singing on everything
i'm gonna bring some sisters in that
[ __ ] yeah bring yeah yeah
shout out to em yeah the legend but now
um
as far as like you're you're you know
what you're a fan of right now artists
who inspire you right now who's out
there that you're like really just like
man i'm i'm just a fan
politics aside i just [ __ ] with your
[ __ ]
um
let's see
uh
well tierrock for sure you know what i'm
saying uh [ __ ] with school boy heavy um
kendrick of course uh like kendrick
versus on that family ty is crazy yeah
yeah that's just better than drake's
whole album that verse
he says
i said it not you he smoked on your top
five
uh
[ __ ] who else we got of course like cole
i [ __ ] with cole uh the jids you know
anderson pack uh
[ __ ] man uh tyler is [ __ ] really
killing it right now yeah his album is
so crazy yeah bro he he put a whole
rapping ass gangsta grills out this
album of the year he's in a he's in a
different bat right now yeah um
oh man
of course three stacks i'm still waiting
to goddamn did you get him or some [ __ ]
did you hear the kanye song oh my god
i'm like how did this not make the album
i mean that second verse that kaye came
i was like what's he doing like he kind
of just ruined like what the what was
going on the vibe of the song it's like
bro did you not just hear andre pour his
[ __ ] heart out yo you come here
talking some other [ __ ] i mean maybe
that's why it just didn't come out yeah
yeah i get it but yeah no um
of course like i'm waiting i'm waiting
bro for the day that
and i'm sending three stacks of [ __ ]
song bro like bro it feel you know what
it feels like with andre base like when
i saw him put out that statement about
that song where he was like i'd love to
work with kendrick i'm like i feel like
he would do a lot more verses if people
would just ask yeah people reached out
to me i don't think people reach out to
him because i just feel like people
think he's unobtainable yeah man people
gotta find his ass you know saying he's
just saying random places [ __ ] you
know i'm saying man
playing a flute and yeah crazy some
people might say they saw him in a
concert or some [ __ ] is andre like
you're
like
number one yeah all time yeah three
stacks yeah i think andre's uh he's in
my top five man yeah i'll go i feel like
outcast is undisputably the greatest
hip-hop group of all time yeah
yeah i just closed close with the
i think that i think for me it's it's
it's outcast and then i like wu-tang
tribe that's my three multi-track
those are kind of my personal thing
i might say try
yeah yeah
outcast wu-tang tribe
and then from there it's like really
whatever you're into gangstar mob i mean
gangstar primo wasn't rapping yeah
mob deep yeah
i mean nwa see but me but like nwa i
just like that [ __ ] was before i know
let me soldiers
you remember uh every time you'd get a
no limit album there'd be all these
[ __ ] albums that like every like
you'd be like yo when the [ __ ] is
this little soldier's album
yeah mercedes rear end
bro you know how many times i touched
myself as a kid to that album cover
that was the closest thing to [ __ ] i
had i've been like yo let me know let me
see mercedes [ __ ] crotch on this
[ __ ] album
it was like mad i never heard none of
the music never
how many no there were so many no limit
artists like that sons of harmony
a bunch of mac
yeah bro uh fiend was dope though
there's one in every family was fire
and then also how many different
versions of the 504 boys album was
promoted oh yeah 504 every no limit
album you'd buy be like 504 boys coming
soon and it'd be like one version would
have like
c murders
mr cool
pee
and silk in it and then the next album
you buy it'd be like five or four boys
coming soon with snoop dogg in the five
or four yeah
that's [ __ ]
i've been waiting for this [ __ ] for two
years yeah yeah
i used to have a no limit chain as a kid
i think we got they had the tank on them
the little silver guy from the mall from
the beauty supply store and then they
put their [ __ ] clothes out and i
couldn't afford i was trying to get one
of them no limit 99 jerseys and mr rags
but this was like a hundred dollars and
i could never afford these yeah and i
see man we got them yeah man we just i
never had the masterpiece you had a flea
market [ __ ] you ever get the masterpiece
sneakers hell no i think by that point i
think i was kind of just like yeah you
know what was crazy
hey the no limit [ __ ] was so popping and
then it just wasn't really fast that's
how it goes that's how i go bro but like
so fast yeah that's how it goes
sometimes it was like the hottest [ __ ]
in the world and then it was just over
yeah man and it was i feel like the last
master p album where i was like oh this
[ __ ] ain't it it's the only guy can
judge me [ __ ] with the cross the the
diamond out cross on the front i
remember i listened to that [ __ ] i was
like no
it's over with so and then he put out
the album where he had uh he he was in
his hornets jersey on the basketball
court on the cover
yeah man ghetto i think mp the last dawn
was probably the last no limit album i
really [ __ ] with i was hearing what
they got now i kind of like to hatch it
was the one that was like the 3d cover
with the top hat and then the rings and
[ __ ] had make them say part two on it
yeah i remember that
yeah
see he had movies and [ __ ] unlocked like
oh i got the hookup was fire come on bro
i got the hookup was so slept on bro
yeah i think like p's like obviously you
know shout out to p man that's one guy i
have an interview
if i ever interviewed him bfp the
pac-man's calling me in the middle of an
interview let's see what he says
i'm in the middle of an interview right
now bro
hey this is my producer he ain't sending
me the folder hey hey cook what the [ __ ]
are we doing right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
my god i got you i'm gonna get you a
photo right now let me finish i'm in the
middle of an interview
[Music]
gonna be on your ass man i need i need
to interview two [ __ ] you you [ __ ] with
bfb the pac-man oh no no i never have
you heard of him nah
oh my god he's like the bro he's like
the funniest rapper a lot matter of fact
man matter of fact you're fighting this
[ __ ] you play this [ __ ] from me
he's [ __ ] hilarious he's from flint
michigan he's from michigan and [ __ ]
right oh yeah
yeah yeah we watched this [ __ ] yeah we
watched it he was cold bro he was so
funny he was cold
yeah that's dope yeah no he's like the
funniest rapper he'd be just saying
normal [ __ ] that we all be thinking but
he'd just be saying it he's saying that
[ __ ] yeah he cold he called i i watched
the [ __ ] and [ __ ] all night with this
[ __ ] we was just going down a little
rabbit hole yeah yeah yeah the pac-man
rabbit hole gets deep man yeah it's hard
what was the [ __ ] we were just talking
about oh masterpiece shout out to master
anyway respect to master p respect to no
limit records
it did end fast
what's your favorite no limit album
[ __ ] i don't know true to the game maybe
i don't know
i [ __ ] with that ghetto dope ghetto dog
heart okay it'll be hard you know may
crack like this man
bourbon singing was it burgers
the bourbon is relaxed
and i missed my homies was crazy oh yeah
yeah
now you're right
so yeah man i don't know bro ghetto d is
like no limits
yeah ghetto d is there though
but then like of course you got like the
[ __ ] ugk
of course you know obviously how about
this outside of cast
even outside of the dungeon family right
because goody mob's incredible but like
who was some southern influences coming
up as an mc that really you know kind of
helped shape your your style that was
like oh [ __ ] there's other [ __ ]
out here that really got barbecued yeah
obviously besides a tip scarface
scarface um
[ __ ]
uh actually uh uh my [ __ ] shawn jay
from philma is a [ __ ] monster
he had a he had a bar on one of his
songs where he said uh
so poor i forget something about the
soap being so small oh yeah yeah like
everybody was soaked inside the size of
a certain was it that's yes yeah bro
like hey nah he got bars man hey if
y'all
was crazy from the router to the tutor
man from the rooted to the tutor sanjay
got bars dog female was crazy
yeah nah nah they're slept on i wonder
yeah that's that's crazy i forgot about
field mode
and they have some hits too that driver
hell yeah so what
at one point you know it was like we was
on a luda [ __ ] you know ludo was hard
hey that ti freestyle that did it for me
he had a jack and for beats freestyle
my name is said it before that one yes
and when he said uh
what did he say uh
i'm like uh uh like martin luther king
with a g-a-t
cause the haters want to alleviate me
exceptionally
oh my god but see he had an older one
man when he was like just going by tilt
that he had a jacket for beats that was
hard bro like he had like
he was doing biggie beats and some
motion on that [ __ ] bro like but yeah
now tips definitely uh
coming out of atlanta bro like
that [ __ ] was huge you know would you
ever want to do a obviously with tyler
kind of bringing back the gangster girls
thing would you ever want to do a
gangster girls because i feel like
that's like a you know obviously growing
up that was a big deal yeah of course
but [ __ ] now i feel like we in a day and
age that
now people just gonna be like oh you
copy you copying off that tyler and it's
like
you know tyler got down he just was just
kind of paying homage to
that to error and [ __ ] so but you know
how people did it nowadays so i would
probably just do it with it was there
any uh
any sort of competition as far as
whether or not you signed with shady
were there other people you were
considering signing with um
kind of but this [ __ ] just made them
this [ __ ] made the most sense you know
what i'm saying like it was
you know a few people man i ain't
talking i talked to some people saying
stan and [ __ ] you know i don't know if
they feel the way or what but oh you
think like maybe because you passed
through the day that yeah yeah yeah just
a little bit people are weirdos man
a little bit it's called business it's a
business move man like the end of the
day like doesn't mean without friends
yeah man
i'll step forward
music industry people are just emotional
[ __ ] man yeah man but see
sometimes man i ain't gonna lie bro like
a few deals fell through and [ __ ] and i
kind of like
see that [ __ ] gave me like a chip on my
shoulder and [ __ ] so like you had you
had deals fall through yeah so like even
the like the anr's or whoever that was
bringing the deals to the table and [ __ ]
like i slick just like didn't talk to
him for a while and [ __ ]
and they're not like i was mad at them
because i know like it ain't your fault
you're presenting this [ __ ] to you know
i'm saying to the bosses and [ __ ] but
you know so i i got to get over that
type of [ __ ] you know so i would chip on
my shoulder and [ __ ] you know i mean
yeah yeah yeah nice
hey man the most emotional friends i
have
are artists
because it's it's like you almost have
to be an emotional person to give a [ __ ]
that much to get so good at something
yeah and it's art right so you're it's
it's literally how you watch the last
dance of course [ __ ] matter
anything anything
and when you're talking about art like
this is like literally like your blood
sweat and tears right right you really
you don't understand
it's not like you're you're you're like
a contractor and you put in flooring or
something right like all right now this
is my art bro this is like my expression
this is my my everything the life you're
putting out here man you know i'm saying
and putting out here for the world to
hear well look the album is out um and
you're working it's not even your shady
records day abuse yeah
just distribute it you got the distress
it's the debut release i'm gonna say
debut album yeah what is it like um you
know obviously paul's a guy who is a
legendary executive you know who's
running def jam for a few years
has managed a bunch of big art i mean
eminem but also you know he's managing
action for a little bit what's paul like
you know i feel like we don't really
know a lot about paul as far as like
most executives are a little bit more
out there
um
than than he is as far as doing
interviews and [ __ ] like how is he yeah
man uh paul's paul is cool man i
i heard
so many different things before you know
what i'm saying getting into the
situation about paul you know so like
just from everywhere so like
you know i kind of just like washed that
out and and went in ready to just like
assess it myself you know get your own
opinion yeah so man so far so good man
cool man you know we
him and t talked all the time and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying shooting text
messages and [ __ ] so
you know yeah paul's cool man like from
from what i've you know i mean and
meeting them and [ __ ] you know how big
did you go to eminem's house when you
went to detroit oh we went to the studio
oh yeah like he's got his own studio
right i'm sure he hasn't yeah he has his
own studio but yeah so you went to
detroit though yeah yeah i went to
detroit is that like you got to go to
like i feel like eminem's not going
nowhere you gotta go to detroit yeah
you're gonna come to detroit like
whenever i see like eminem somewhere
else besides michigan i'm like what's
going on
he was in la for what
it must be working on the detox or
something all right all right you're
gonna pull up to detroit you know you
know if he's working on any new music
himself because his uh music to be
murdered by the best [ __ ] he's put out
in like 10 years hard though right oh
incredible yeah the luck too i might do
that i'm not gonna lie i said this you
know because i've been very critical of
him and his music over the last
eight or nine years music to be murdered
by
at the end of the year was like my
second most listed it made me feel like
vintage eminem i felt like he handled
some production it sounded cause you you
know back in the day and would you you
know it's crazy because i don't think
eminem ever got enough love as a
producer because he had a yeah he had a
literal sound yeah he's nasty he's nasty
and but m had a sound where you'd be
like oh no those are eminem drums this
sounds like an eminem beat like when he
did the cross for knives or whatever
like you know i said mb
and i feel like he kind of got back to
like
that yeah
cause man i ain't me shout
being listen bro skyla gray man
skylar [ __ ] grey man
man when i saw music be murdered by i
looked at the [ __ ] tracklist and i
got so mad because i saw her name on
there again but she was cool on this one
god damn this [ __ ] on everybody and it's
like and it's crazy because like you got
to tell my man my man is a fat you know
what i'm saying like you're like a
evil why is she on bad meets evil
i want to hear skylar grace singing a
ballad hook on bad meets evil
shout out to her she she owes a lot to
him you know what i'm saying yeah hey
man listen well look
we're gonna do a freestyle separate
youtube video the album is out
i know eminem and paul's gonna watch
this at least paul will
i love eminem
next album just leave skylar grey off
that [ __ ] for me please jesus
christ all right there we go